et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Charlotte cobel bonjour bon merci
beaucoup d'être là secrétaire d'État
chargée de l'enfance on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour Oriane bonjour Charles on a
évidemment beaucoup de dossiers à un lit
à l'enfance à la petite enfance à voir
avec vous mais d'abord quelques mots de
politique puisque on a appris hier que
la Commission la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales à
l'Assemblée nationale qui est donc
membre de la majorité présidentielle a
saisi Eric Coquerel le président de la
commission des finances sur la
recevabilité de la proposition de loi du
groupe lutte pour abroger la réforme des
retraites est-ce que la majorité
présidentielle l'exécutive vont tout
faire pour que ce débat n'est pas lieu
alors je crois quand même que cette
proposition de loi il faut le dire elle
est absolument inacceptable
politiquement puisqu'elle vient
potentiellement annuler 175 heures de
débat donc en ce sens la majorité est
quand même contre le principe même
qu'une proposition de loi Vienne annuler
tous les débats qui ont eu autour de ça
et puis évidemment on a un gros sujet
autour de la
fin de l'impact de cette loi notamment
en matière de finance publique puisque
tranquillement elle est face enfin elle
impose 12 milliards d'euros de plus de
dépenses dans notre pays donc oui on
fera tout pour que ce débat n'est pas
lieu il est illégitime politiquement
techniquement et il met en danger à
nouveau nos finances publiques à nouveau
de l'île sur le feu est-ce qu'il ne
voudrais pas mieux que ce n'est pas élu
à l'Assemblée puisque vraisemblablement
de toute manière le Sénat de votre appel
texte de manière à permettre un dernier
débat vous avez compris quand même que
l'opposition cherche
à chercher à complètement phagocyter
embolir le débat et maintenant je
cherche à réouvrir un débat qui a lieu
donc on peut continuer avec ce débat à
faire tout pour faire en sorte qu'il de
déterminer qu'il n'est pas eu lieu en
réalité ce débat a eu on le redit il y a
eu 175 heures de débat au total ils en a
pas voté allez national très bien et
parce que justement elle se sont
elles-mêmes trop trouvées prises à leur
propre jeu avec je le rappelle un
tombeau d'amendements qui ont bloqué le
délai de les délais et qui ont fait que
effectivement on est passé au 49 3 mais
est-ce que objectivement on peut
concevoir dans ce pays qu'une loi qui
était adoptée validée par le Conseil
consuel soit totalement remise en cause
par une proposition de loi d'un seul
groupe qui vient par ailleurs je le
répète non seulement revenir sur le
principe de la loi mais augmenter
sensiblement les dépenses de l'État mais
je repose ma question on craignait pas
que ça jette de l'huile sur le feu à
nouveau là les compétitions de loi qui
rejettent de l'huile sur le feu alors
même que on le voit pour beaucoup de
régions la contestation et les
manifestations
ont trouvé retrouver un certain calme
c'est cette proposition de loi qui
rejette de l'huile sur le feu
à sombrevin aujourd'hui
la gauche organise une manifestation
pour dénoncer les violences d'extrême
droite la majorité sera absente est-ce
que c'est un bon signal à envoyer ce
qu'il aurait pas fallu que tous les
partis politiques soient unis dans ce
mouvement là ce qui est important c'est
l'engagement que la majorité a pour
venir au soutien de l'ensemble des élus
qui subissent aujourd'hui
massivement des violences absolument
inacceptables qui remettent en cause
notre démocratie un certain nombre de
textes un certain nombre de démarches
portées notamment pour le ministre de la
justice vise à mieux protéger et à
devenir au soutien de nos élus la
manifestation qui est organisée avec un
prisme politique quand même assez fort
la majorité a considéré que c'était pas
sa place et qu'au contraire il fallait
être dans l'action pour protéger au
maximum nos élus qui sont évidemment
l'objet de violence absolument
inacceptable pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a
vu que c'était pas sa place
au gouvernement en charge de mener des
actions
peut-être
nous faut-il être évidemment enfin pas
de peut-être il nous faut être en action
et pas nécessairement en manifestation
sur ce on s'est déjà beaucoup exprimé la
première mise est exprime à l'Assemblée
nationale tout les membres du
gouvernement évidemment ce sont
élevés contre la situation et regrets
déplore une tristesse absolue quand même
de voir ce qui s'est passé là-bas notre
objectif à nous c'est d'être dans
l'action et d'être de faire tout pour
que
une reconstruction du lien entre nos
citoyens et nos élus c'est tout à fait
essentiel on va parler des dossiers qui
concernent les enfants la petite enfance
ils sont nombreux d'abord vous préparer
votre plan un plan pour lutter contre
les violences faites aux enfants et ça
présentait dans deux semaines on
conseille des ministres quels sont les
premières pistes quelles sont les
grandes lignes alors d'abord c'est un
plan qui est un plan numéro de parce que
dans le précédent quinquennat il y a un
plan
2019-2022 il a eu plusieurs dizaines de
mesures et qui ont été quasiment toutes
mis en oeuvre grâce à l'investissement
de l'ensemble des ministères qui ont été
engagés sur ce plan mais ça ne suffit
alors il en manque quelques-unes mais
vraiment globalement si je parle
notamment de l'installation de la
civisme si je parle donc de la
commission indépendante des victimes
d'infraction sexuelles si je parle bien
sûr des up des unités d'accueil
pédiatriques 30 ans de la parole de
l'enfant beaucoup de choses très
importantes ont été faites dans le
précédent plan et il faut saluer que ce
plan a été conduit néanmoins ça fait un
an que je suis à mon poste et je ne peux
que mesurer que nous n'arrivons pas à
mobiliser suffisamment notre pays sur la
réalité des violences faites aux enfants
on est enfin arrivé à le faire sur les
violences faites aux femmes aujourd'hui
la question des violences faites aux
enfants pardonnez-moi mais ne passe pas
le mur du son on n'entend pas que un
enfant meurt tous les cinq jours dans
son environnement familial on n'entend
pas que à peu près deux enfants par
classe sub un jour un phénomène
d'inceste donc ça il faut quand même que
ça rentre dans la tête de l'ensemble des
adultes pour plusieurs raisons est
agressé toutes les trois minutes voilà
ça fait un chiffre d'après les chiffres
de la civisme donc il faut quand même
l'entendre et ça doit interpeller tous
les adultes que nous sommes à la fois
dans notre comportement à l'égard des
enfants que ce soit dans les violences
éducatives ordinaires mais évidemment
dans les violences encore plus
évidemment destructrice que sont les
violences sexuelles mais ça doit aussi
interpeller chaque adulte pour repérer
les signaux faibles et porter la parole
des enfants excusez-moi mais justement
pour les violences faites aux femmes et
une grosse campagne de communication de
la part du gouvernement depuis des
années c'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
tout à fait l'opinion publique s'en est
saisi est-ce que ça a été suffisamment
fait alors non l'enfance merci de
m'envoyer cette balle effectivement à la
rentrée scolaire prochaine nous ferons
une campagne que je souhaite à la fois
de porter de dimensions et d'impact
quasiment identique à la sécurité
routière notamment en nous mettant du
point de vue de l'enfant et du
traumatisme que qu'on que constitue les
violences pour les enfants donc une
campagne de campagne choc que je
souhaite évidemment pouvoir relayer très
largement sur l'ensemble des médias et
comme les campagnes de sécurité routière
parce qu'effectivement il faut une prise
de conscience on a déjà eu du mal avec
les femmes et pardonnez-moi je suis pas
en compétition ces deux combats qui sont
à la fois qui se recoupent sur certains
aspects mais qui sont aussi un peu
distincts on a eu du mal avec les femmes
avec les enfants il y a un petit côté
que je n'arrive pas à décrypter qui est
c'est pas possible qu'on fasse ça à des
enfants il y a toujours une explication
on veut pas voir c'est dans les familles
un petit côté caché il y a une forme
d'omerta quand même sur le sujet des
enfants et eux-mêmes évidemment ont du
mal à porter leur propre parole à
fortiori si je parle des nourrissons je
vous rappelle quand même doublement du
nombre de bébés secoués depuis la crise
sanitaire donc on a 400 enfants chaque
année qui deviennent handicapés à vie du
fait des secousses qui ont subi donc
vraiment un mécanisme des violences de
toute nature qu'il faut prendre en
compte et donc une campagne choc à la
rentrée ça ne suffit exactement avec un
slogan on imagine qu'il va frapper les
esprits avec un slogan avec vous l'avez
déjà trouvé peut-être une mascotte enfin
vraiment des choses qui qui qui faut
qu'on
retrouve et ça sera une première on fera
une première campagne probablement
autour de l'inceste et des violences
intrafamidales qui aujourd'hui quand
même détruisent détruisent de nombreuses
vies et puis ta boule inceste
aujourd'hui alors évidemment quand vous
dites mais faites un sondage votre de
vous bah titre personnel fait un sondage
dans dans votre famille deux enfants
dans une classe d'âge subiront l'inceste
on vous dit mais non alors l'inceste
quand je parle d'inceste c'est violence
intrafamiliales entre frères et sœurs
parents enfants oncle etc donc c'est
quelque chose ou globalement dit non ce
n'est pas possible ce n'est pas possible
voilà et en plus l'inceste par rapport à
d'autres types de violences sexuelles et
en plus difficile à accepter qu'il va
détruire la famille il va détruire le
couple si l'un des deux est agresseur il
va détruire l'environnement familial il
y aura les pour il y aura les comptes
ceux qui sont donc c'est extrêmement
compliqué c'est un tabou et il y a une
véritable omerta sur ça il faut laver
pardon juste un après je te donne pas le
Christelle mais donc dans ce plan il y
aura la campagne choc qui sera lancé en
septembre et il y aura quoi une
plateforme la mise en place d'une
plateforme d'écoute de l'ensemble des
professionnels de l'enfance parce que
fréquemment et ce n'est pas ce n'est
vraiment pas un reproche dans dans ma
bouche un certain nombre de
professionnels repère des signaux
faibles et puis ils se disent toujours
que les signaux sont trop faibles et que
finalement ils ne sont pas les mieux
placés pour en parler un certain nombre
de professionnels aussi ont des enjeux
de secret professionnel je pense
notamment au corps médical vous le savez
on a une polémique autour du secret des
médecins donc l'idée c'est d'accompagner
chaque professionnel dans leur
déontologie professionnelle mais surtout
dans leur mécanique de
autour du signaux faible d'autre part
nous souhaitons évidemment vraiment
industrialiser ce qu'on appelle le
criblage de la probité de l'ensemble des
professionnels et des bénévoles qui
tournent autour des enfants c'est une
obligation qui découle du doigt du 7
février 22 maintenant il faut vraiment
que la moindre personne qui rentre dans
un foyer qui rentre dans une école on en
vérifie évidemment la probité voilà ces
trois axes en particulier mais
évidemment il y a beaucoup d'autres
dispositifs je continue le parallèle
avec ce qui a été fait concernant les
violences faites aux femmes beaucoup a
été fait auprès des services de police
pour que les plantes soient mieux
accueillies aujourd'hui c'est pas
forcément le cas concernant les plantes
concernant les enfants est-ce que vous
travaillez avec Gérald Darmanin
là-dessus est-ce que quelque chose va
être fait
paradoxalement sur le sujet des enfants
cette question de la formation et de la
sensibilisation des professionnels elle
date de très longtemps c'est les
fameuses lois Guigou de 1998 qui ont
cherché déjà à élargir la prescription
et apprendre en compte la parole de
l'enfant moi je le dis on a eu l'affaire
Outreau qui a tétanisé la chaîne
judiciaire et aujourd'hui il faut
dépasser ou trop ce que nous livre la
civisme fait que nous ne pouvons plus
nous arrêter à cette situation qui a
découlé notamment de l'affaire de trop
qui a quand même beaucoup compliqué les
choses
de nombreux professionnels sont formés
et là ça fait partie aussi du plan la
civisme a mis en place un dispositif de
formation de l'ensemble des
professionnels qu'on va diffuser qu'on a
déjà commencé à diffuser avec par
exemple agnès-sur-mer le Bodo on va dans
quelques jours continuer à aller vers
les professionnels avec cette formation
bien sûr les enquêteurs sont au cœur de
nos priorités je vous rappelle que
Gérald Darmanin a annoncé pour la
rentrée prochaine la création d'un
office de dédié aux violences graves
faites aux enfants le garder sceau a
pris il y a quelques semaines une
circulaire sur les violences faites aux
enfants donc on a vraiment sur ce sujet
là qui est la priorité numéro 1 fixée
par la première mise dans le cadre du
comité intermissal de l'enfance une
véritable coopération entre l'ensemble
des ministres je pourrais parler de
l'action aussi de améliodéat dans le
sport bref on est tous très unis sur ce
sujet là Macron on a fait une des
priorités pendant sa campagne électorale
or depuis un an d'entendre parler
pouvoir d'achat on entend parler
retraite immigration aujourd'hui est
très peu d'enfants est-ce que vous avez
été un peu noyé par l'actualité alors il
y a beaucoup de sujets d'actualité mais
j'allais dire que tous ces sujets là
pardonnez-moi souvent ont un volet
enfance je le dis et je n'ai pas dit au
moment où vous m'avez posé la question
mais même le suivi retraite il est aussi
pour nos enfants
oui alors oui et non on a beaucoup de
thématiques et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
ma mission auprès de la première
ministre de faire en sorte convergence
de l'ensemble de l'ensemble des sujets
en matière de santé par exemple la
question de la santé des enfants qui est
portée des questions de santé et la
Commission de la santé des enfants est
au cœur des priorités du ministère de la
santé des Assises de la santé de la
santé mentale des enfants donc on parle
beaucoup en
mon rôle à moi c'est de faire vivre le
collectif de l'action pour l'enfance bah
écoutez merci de me donner la parole ce
matin pour le mettre en valeur
une mesure très symbolique qui a été
mise en avant pendant la campagne
électorale par le candidat Macron et le
service public de la petite enfance ou
est-ce que son on est aujourd'hui alors
c'est au cœur de la démarche du Conseil
national de la refondation de portée par
Jean-Christophe combe qui porte le
déploiement du service public de la
petite enfance il y a quand même une
ambition très forte de son et de plus de
100000 personnes
alors aujourd'hui en fait il y a des
discussions qui sont extrêmement
importantes entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales qui ont un
partage de compétences sur ce sujet là
il y a des discussions actuellement
enfin des travaux autour de ce qu'on
appelle la convention d'orientation de
la Caisse d'allocations familiales qui
est le principal financeur donc il y a
des discussions budgétaires et je pense
que les principales annonces arriveront
au moment du budget sur ce sujet là il y
a un peu moins un peu plus d'un mois
pardon un rapport de Liga serait révélé
des situations de maltraitance dans de
nombreuses crèches de nombreuses
structures d'accueil de jeunes enfants
il se rapporte faisait une trentaine de
recommandations aujourd'hui où on en est
que fait le gouvernement alors
Jean-Christophe s'en est saisi tout de
suite et nous travaillons évidemment
conjointement sur ce sujet là je
voudrais qu'on distingue deux types de
situations la situation à nouveau des
violences faites aux enfants des
violences volontaires faites aux enfants
ce qui était notamment le cas de Lyon
qui a provoqué cette qui a provoqué
cette inspection ces violences sont
inacceptables il faut y travailler y
compris avec les professionnels après on
a un sujet de qualité de la prise en
charge qui fait partie enfin qui est
largement décrite dans dans ce rapport
et cette qualité elle passe par
plusieurs choses bien sûr les exigences
posées par le gouvernement auprès des
opérateurs de crèche les contrôles fait
par le gouvernement et par l'État sur
ces crèches qu'il faut bien évidemment
renforcer et évidemment tous les enjeux
de recrutement on le dit on le répète
dans notre pays aujourd'hui dans le
champ de l'accompagnement et en
particulier dans le champ de l'enfance
mais évidemment on peut parler aussi du
chant de de nos seniors on a une vraie
difficulté de recrutement on a une
problématique voilà ça c'est quelque
chose que nous travaillons au niveau du
gouvernement de nouveau en interne
mystériel pour rendre plus attractif
c'est qu'il y aura des mesures alors
d'abord il y a une campagne aussi de
recrutement et Jean-Christophe combe est
en train de finaliser les travaux qui
ont été portés par une conférence des
métiers avec l'ensemble des acteurs de
la petite enfance évidemment nous avons
un sujet assez majeur sur lequel nous
travaillons tous des conventions
collectives sont encore du discussion
tous ensemble on a évidemment des enjeux
ça c'est impossible et Jean-Christophe
kompson il s'est dit et moi au titre de
la protection de l'enfance évidemment je
suis particulièrement vigilante à la
mise en oeuvre de la plupart des
recommandations de ce rapport le Sénat a
hier soir un texte vous étiez d'ailleurs
dans l'hémicycle pour instaurer une
majorité numérique c'est un texte qui
vient de l'Assemblée nationale et qui
fait consensus il a été voté à une très
large majorité dans les deux chambres
instaurer une majorité numérique pour
que les enfants ne puissent plus
s'inscrire sur un réseau social sans
l'accord parental avant l'âge de 15 ans
est-ce que c'est effectivement
réalisable on a compris que c'était un
texte qui était fait pour envoyer un
signal pour susciter le débat est-ce que
cette majorité numérique elle pourrait
être effective alors quels sont nos
objectifs en matière de risque de danger
de lutte contre les risques et dangers
sur internet pour nos enfants on a
plusieurs types de risques d'abord
effectivement l'addiction aux écrans
l'addiction à certains contenus des
écrans d'autre part les violences
commises sur les enfants par le biais
d'internet je pense aussi bien
harcèlement la protection de l'image qui
est un troisième événement et bien sûr
tous les enjeux de pédocriminalité quels
sont nos leviers
former éduquer nos enfants sensibiliser
former les familles aujourd'hui 40% des
familles ne savent absolument pas quoi
faire avec le numérique des enfants il y
a quelques semaines nous avons fait une
campagne extrêmement dynamique pour dire
vous apprenez à vos enfants nager
apprenez à vos enfants à surfer sur le
net ce texte il a pour donc ça c'est les
deux premières axes éducation
sensibilisation des familles et
responsabilisation des acteurs du
numérique vous ne pouvez pas vous laver
les mains de ce qui se passe vous aussi
vous avez une responsabilité de protéger
les enfants sur sur le net il faut
sanctionner les plateformes alors nous
avons la chance grâce d'ailleurs à
l'action extrêmement dynamique de la
France d'avoir un texte européen de
textes TSA DMA je vais pas rentrer dans
la technique que Jean-Noël Barrault dont
Jean-Noël barreau portera la
transposition dans quelques temps avec
un texte qui nous permet déjà d'avoir
des leviers à l'égard des plateformes je
vous rappelle qu'il y a quelques jours
mais tu as été sanctionné violemment sur
des sujets de protection des données
donc on commence à avoir les leviers de
discussion avec les ce texte là de porté
par Laurent Marc Angeli il est important
parce que en fixant une majorité
numérique il dit aux parents en dessous
de 15 ans vous ne pouvez pas ne pas vous
intéresser à ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux avec vos enfants il dit aux
enfants la même chose vous êtes obligé
d'en prendre en discussion avec vos
parents et il dit au plateformes il est
de votre responsabilité de vérifier ce
qui se passe en dessous de 15 ans vous
pouvez vous donner un exemple chaque
mois
meta ou Tik Tok supprime grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle qui a
certains beaux côtés des contes
d'enfants de 10 ou 11 ans on se rend
donc compte des contenus qui traduisent
la le très jeune âge de la personne qui
est sur qui est sur le réseau donc avec
des mécanismes d'intelligence
artificielle avec des mécanismes de
vérification d'âge on arrivera à mettre
en place ce seuil de 15 ans qui me
paraît tout à fait essentiel vous avez
pointé du doigt un réseau par
particulier ces derniers temps TikTok
est-ce qu'il y a un Tik Tok vous
dénonciez par exemple des incitations à
l'automutilation j'ai fait la
vérification moi-même en effet ça existe
pourquoi est-ce que rien n'est fait
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est si
compliqué alors vous parlez d'une
interdiction plus récente pour les
adolescents est-ce que c'est toujours à
l'ordre du jour en tout cas ça fait
partie bien évidemment des leviers que
le gouvernement n'hésitera pas à mettre
en oeuvre si Tic-Toc ne rentre pas ou ne
maintient pas son action de renforce pas
son action dans les dialogues dans le
dialogue que le gouvernement sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République qui a mis en place le
laboratoire protection de l'enfance le
10 novembre dernier si Tik Tok ne
participe pas totalement sincèrement aux
travaux que nous avons huit aujourd'hui
il y a des discussions dans ce
laboratoire le président relèvera les
copies le 10 novembre prochain donc
autant vous dire que le calendrier on
l'a on l'a Tic-Toc vient d'envoyer
quelques signaux positifs notamment lui
cette plateforme va afficher
pardonnez-moi le temps d'écran
le temps d'utilisation de Tik Tok c'est
toujours pas le cas aujourd'hui donc ici
sont engagés donc on verra l'innovant
mars engagé donc il y a deux trois
sujets moi je sais que j'ai des
relations extrêmement régulières avec
les acteurs français de Tik Tok et quand
il y a des choses qui me dérangent je
constate que si je les signale sa réagit
quand même extrêmement vite donc on est
dans un dialogue extrêmement ferme si ce
dialogue n'aboutit pas à résoudre ces
problématiques de notamment de messages
totalement viraux qui conduisent à des
problématiques de santé de santé mentale
et de santé physique de nos enfants je
pense que le président et le
gouvernement n'aura aucune hésitation on
se laisse jusqu'au 10 novembre prochain
notamment puisque le président relèvera
les copies de ce que de manière de
mettre la pression sur Tik Tok pour
totalement il faut être aussi assez
réaliste moi on en a beaucoup discuté
notamment avec Jean-Noël Barrault
l'interdiction pure et simple d'un
certain nombre de réseaux est
aujourd'hui
quelque chose de pas facile à réaliser
par ailleurs on sait aussi que tik bien
pris et bien poussé peut inciter des
enfants et participer à au développement
d'un certain nombre de passions
positives donc on est toujours dans une
logique de dialogue si le dialogue
n'aboutit pas à des objectifs qui sont
les nôtres qui sont la santé la sécurité
de nos enfants on aura aucun état d'âme
un dernier sujet qu'on voudrait aborder
avec vous il en reste deux petites
minutes c'est la question des mineurs
étrangers isolés les mineurs non
accompagnés c'est un sujet sur lequel
vous travaillez vous avez notamment
travaillé dessus avec Gérald Darmanin
avec François sauvadec qui est le
président de l'Assemblée de départements
de France les départements sont inquiets
par de situations explosives est-ce
qu'il faut les aider est-ce que l'État
va les aider financièrement alors
d'abord l'état aide aujourd'hui
financièrement les départements sur
cette question là puisque pas
suffisamment le reste à charge est
énorme l'État finance notamment toute la
partie préalable à l'évaluation de la
minorité jusqu'à ce que la personne qui
se prétend mineure soit qualifiée mineur
c'est l'État qui finance à la fois
l'évaluation et la mise à l'abri mais on
est dans une situation évidemment
extrêmement particulière la réouverture
des frontières la crise sanitaire la
crise l'inflation etc font qu'on a une
forte pression et qu'on voit arriver
aujourd'hui non seulement des enfants en
nombre comme il y a trois ou quatre ans
mais aussi des enfants beaucoup plus
jeunes c'est évidemment un enjeu
extrêmement fort pour les départements
parce qu'en vertu de nos conventions
internationales auxquelles je tiens il y
a quelques semaines j'étais à l'ONU pour
défendre le la place de la France dans
le respect de la convention
internationale des droits des enfants
c'est un message républicain ça c'est un
message j'aurais pu mettre en cause les
traité et il ne faut pas remettre en
cause et traité qu'il soit européen et
qu'il soit nos conventions
internationales un enfant isolé doit
être protégé dans le dispositif de
protection de l'enfance une fois qu'on a
dit ça il est de ma responsabilité et de
celle du gouvernement d'être aux côtés
des départements pour que cette afflux
d'enfants mineurs isolé ne viennent pas
mettre en difficulté de manière majeure
les départements qui ont déjà forte
affaires parce que dans le contexte de
violence dont je vous ai parlé sur les
enfants aujourd'hui dans certains
départements on a plus de 30% en plus de
placement d'enfants de notre territoire
et donc ce double afflux de mineur isolé
et d'enfants à placer mais en difficulté
l'ensemble de la structure de protection
de l'enfance qui est elle-même déjà en
difficulté
des départements c'est le travail que
financièrement financièrement dans
l'action de l'État l'action de l'État
c'est aussi une école c'est aussi la
santé c'est la justice moi je suis j'ai
mis en place plusieurs comités
départements de protection de l'enfance
sous l'autorité des préfets et des
présidents de départements présents de
l'autorité judiciaire pour que l'action
soit
annoncé en tout cas actuellement nous
travaillons sur toutes ces questions de
financement je trouve ça fait des années
que les départements se plaignent
beaucoup d'argent mais l'État mais aussi
beaucoup d'argent avec l'école la santé
et la justice il faut que tout ça se
corde mieux il faut bien évidemment
évaluer et venir au soutien je pense
notamment au département limitrophes de
la frontière italienne qui voit
aujourd'hui un afflux de mineur nous y
travaillons le président sauvagnier le
sait les présidents des départements le
savent je suis à leur côté l'état
prendra ses responsabilités et permettra
au département
dans les discussions il nous faudra des
décisions à très court terme des
décisions de moyen terme et des
décisions de long terme j'y travaille
avec énormément d'applications merci
Charlotte cobel merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin pour
pas parler de ces sujets évidemment qui
sont très concernant on regarde la Une
de La Dépêche soignant prof élus stop à
la violence c'est à la Une de votre
journal Christelle merci beaucoup merci
Charlotte on passe au club des
territoires